hey leute hier ist jedoch immer
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt und heute machen wir die kirsch
taschen aus seoul afp est la vie judas
ist der zweite teil dieser filmreihe auf
netflix es ist jetzt ein dritter teil
rausgekommen den habe ich allerdings nur
angefangen weil langsam also ich finde
langsam ist das thema da irgendwie durch
ist erhält also falls euch der film noch
gefällt könnt euch aber mich hat der
drittel dann nicht mehr ganz so gehetzt
den zweiten fall nicht noch mehr gut den
ersten fall nicht auch ich gut und falls
ihr den film to all the boys love wie
vor oder die andere teile nicht gesehen
habt der gehört zu dieser kategorie von
riversdale big thing buß was für
deutsche wirklichen zungenbrecher ist
bei kissing buße kissing buß das sind so
die liebes feelgood filme wie high
school musical zum beispiel für die
ältere generation hier
und falls ihr die filme gesehen habt
dann erkennt ihr bestimmt meinen look
lore gene in der house l'origine ist der
hauptcharakter sie hat liebesbriefe
geschrieben und sie in eine box gepackt
und ihre freche schwester hat diese
liebesbriefe verschickt weil sie
unbedingt wollte dass ihre schwester
endlich einen wolf hin findet das so
früh liebesbriefe geschrieben ins tagen
habe ich mal rein geschrieben
in der kiste mit den zeugnissen mit den
bio hausaufgaben die ganzen kommentare
geschrieben dass ich diese kirsch
taschen doch mal machen soll
zu recht denn die szene sind wirklich
aus wie so ein bug tutorial also die
kamera ist halt so oben drauf und sie
bereitet diese kirsch taschen halt zu
für den weit ins tag für ihren freund
ich finde das sehr siehst wie schon
gesagt habe die kamera ist da drüber und
man sieht ganz genau welche zutaten sie
benutzt und das sind sie chili mutter da
könnt ihr euch entscheiden ob ihr
veganer oder echte butter nehmen wir
haben es nicht so gut recherchiert was
wir wissen haben sie vielleicht wegen
der hitze bis drei jahren wird sich
schon butter benutzt und eine prise salz
und das sind tatsächlich die zutaten
also mehr passiert da nicht ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass das es wird ja so
eine konsistenz also so eine kruste
einfach sein weil tisch taschen ja
eigentlich eher so ein blätterteig haben
und wenn man online nachtisch taschen
sucht dann bekommt man eigentlich auch
nur rezepte wo halt blätterteig
verwendet wird
den muss man ja nicht selber machen aber
blätterteig aber genau deswegen für
solche fragen gibt es dieses format gern
geschehen für die kirsch füllung
brauchen wir natürlich kirschen aus dem
glas für die kirche stellung hat sie
jetzt nicht wirklich ein tutorial
gemacht deswegen interpretieren wir das
mal ein bisschen selbst und mache ein
bisschen vanille pudding rein damit das
schön anlegt und es in schönefeld und
zum bestreichen
meine wunderbare assistentin hat mich
auch was aufmerksam gemacht zitronensaft
das macht sie noch rein das sieht man
zum bestreichen jetzt kommen wir zum
finale am ende wenn die taschen zusammen
sind benutzt sie eier und sie mit
benutzt zweier was ich ein bisschen
verschwinden
es ist so hell ich habe jetzt draußen so
hell geworden ist wo geht schon
eigentlich
es ist zwar jetzt nicht der wein
dienstag aber ich liebe meinen freund
jeden tag genauso wie wir wollen
dienstag
deswegen mache ich ihn jetzt auch ein
paar kirscht haben hier wahrscheinlich
nicht essen will weil er gerade im sport
modus ist aber es okay sie halt alleine
zum schluss mit dem sie vorbereitet wird
so ein cooles hand sieht das habe ich
nicht und sie benutzt ein kamel dann
benutzen wir auch ein kamel das kommt in
unsere ja gut es macht schon sinn dass
einmal durch zu sehen dann hat man
schöne für eine konsistenz hier
sie benutzt 6 mit der große bruder
stücke das machen wir auch dafür wird
die butter halbiert von den sechs teile
geschnitten und wir haben jetzt noch mal
die butter halbiert weil die stücke so
groß sein müssen die mengenangaben weil
wir schmeckst du denn noch immer besser
1 ich hab das alles vergessen also prise
bad reichenhaller alpen jodsalz ist sie
hat jetzt halt in kundenhand stampfer
ich habe nur ein kartoffelbrei stammt
war let's go aber noch nie gesehen das
ganze so teig vorbereitet hat das kind
zwar durch die vielleicht wenn die
massen so halbwegs angestammtes gibt es
einen viertel cup wasser dazu mit
unserem peter patsche sauberen händen
über die verbesserte kneten dass es
fühlt sich aber sehr geil dann muss ich
sagen es ist unser muttertag hier sieht
man dass ich eine sporthose habe so
arbeitsfläche wird vorbereitet
wir brauchen ein nudelholz fragt welches
vorbereitet und nun kümmern wir uns um
unseren teig wir wohl die mal ganz gut
aus dem kühlschrank
es ist halt ein sehr gut riegert aigner
es tut mir jetzt richtig geil wenn ihr
sagt aber dass er muss vielmehr mir dran
ich arbeite nach vorgabe so wie
manchester und dann wollen wir das geht
erstaunlicherweise hat den kirchen
schütze an meine selbst gestrickte
shirts wirklich selbst bestritt
[Musik]
wir versuchen jetzt mal sechs platten
hier raus zu kriegen
das ist so schied aber ihr war es auch
schon man sieht aber auch in der szene
ein film fehler
sie schneidet voll die schiefen dinger
und wenn es dann darauf legt es
plötzlich sehr schön es klappt ist klar
das wird glaube ich war es und ich habe
sogar noch teig rest unsere decke
bekommen jetzt drei jahre ziehen
irgendwie hier zwischenlagern war jetzt
müssen uns auch um die kirche hat wie
kirschen sind eigentlich relativ schnell
gemacht gebraucht jetzt uns ja sie und
er die kirschen 200
na ja weil es so gehen wir einen schritt
kochen helmstadt und hier haben wir
unsere kirchen die langsam so abtropfen
und ihr wisst zwischendurch mal
probieren dann machen wir unseren hart
an und nehmen unseren kirschsaft und
geben ihn in den top china und dann
nehmen uns auch ein ganz bisschen
kirschsaft für unseren puddingpulver
während das wahnsinn zu kochen und geben
ungefähr die hälfte von unserem pudding
da rein und haben wir das hier erst mal
zusammen gehören
[Musik]
wow kirchen in den topf so nach augenmaß
atmete stil
das sieht nicht aus wie die mit
doppelkinn füllung in london street
abgehört noch der saft einer halben
zitrone rein also sie drückt das dreimal
so rein das ist hier so ein bisschen
fließt eine die kennt sich schon in der
küche aus hieß es
[Musik]
wir heißen jetzt den ofen vor okay dann
machen wir mal diesmal wenig flüssigkeit
[Musik]
war ob man das sieht so schön aus wie
das was ich gemacht habe ich vergessen
wie viel spaß das macht wenn man also
für rezepte ausprobiert nehmen über 32
übertreibt nicht übertreiben nicht
betreiben noch ein so und jetzt kommt
das ist hier unser einmal das wird
unsere angeber tasche sein
das wird so eine tasche seien die wird
stabil und dann kommt jetzt der
zaubertrick warum sie auf keinen fall
auseinander gehen
ganz ehrlich ich stelle jetzt erst mal
ein paar fragen damit die kommentare mal
hier ein bisschen vorankommen bei dieser
verliebt welche motive schreibt euren
beziehungsstatus gerade wie ist das
wetter bei euch holen ihn diese kirschen
auch gerne probieren schreibt mir das
alles in die kommentare
als auch gesehen was ist los mit uns wir
sind nicht die struktur gehen so eine
übertrieben große schüssel für zweier
übertrieben große eier betrieben großer
schneebesen nehmen wir unsere pampe und
schmiert wieder darauf mein gott warum
macht man das
ich glaube für glanz und gloria sieht
gut aus
glas wird sodann mit drin bis sie
goldbraun sind 22 minuten später unsere
taschen sind jetzt fertig und tara und
nehmen uns wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmecken die kirsch taschen
aus to all the boys love wie vor ps the
love you
das ist wirklich der längste titel denen
es gibt sie sich schon sagte ich knackig
aus und gut dass wir das eigentlich
vergessen haben weil das hat glaube ich
viel ausgemacht gerade für die decke und
wie sie von innen aus wenn mir das
jemand am dienstag in der schule geben
würde wäre ich mega happy ich finde aber
blätterteig passt einfach viel besser
für seine tasche es kann aber auch sein
dass wir aus dem norden kommen wir
lieben so franzbrötchen in der mitte
wird so richtig geil wenn da so richtig
viel drin ist der rand ist halt so nee
ist es schon geil schmeckt auf jeden
fall besser als erwartet wenn ihr an den
sonntagmorgen mal eure eltern oder euren
partner überraschen wollen
macht ihn so eine kirsche kirschen in
meinem bauch ich hoffe ihr hattet spaß
und wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
wenn ihr bis hierhin geguckt habe dann
packt ein kirche in die kommentare und
schreibt bitte dazu welches wie schmeckt
ihr noch sehen wollt eure laura gleich
gibt's ja auch noch was in den film
vielleicht macht sie ja noch im tutorial
und ansonsten sehen uns das nächste mal
wieder
vergesst bitte nicht im video einen
daumen nach oben zu geben wenn ihr spaß
hattet und euch das video gefallen hat
das unterstützt mich mal sehr gut und
hier ist mein gaming kanal oder da hier
ist meine mehrkanal oder da hier ist
hier könnt ihr main kanal abonnieren und
da ist noch ein video ihr seht euch das
schmeckt sehr gut ist ja gerade schon
die dritte tasche wir sehen uns dann
bist du dann schieße